عادة ما يكون هناك فقط القتلى الذين يرقدون هنا
في حفر الجبهة الجنوبية لأوكرانيا،
ولكن في بعض الأحيان يضيء بصيص من الحياة في
هذه الطائرة بدون طيار التي ترصد جنديًا أوكرانيًا
يقول إنه انفصل عن وحدته مصابًا
في صدره وساقه بسبب القصف،
وقام بتصوير هذا وهو يرقد وحيدًا وهو ينزف.
كان يخشى أن أي قتال من أجل العيش
لن يكون كافياً، وقال لشبكة CNN لاحقاً
من سريره في المستشفى
إنني مستعد للقتال من أجل حياتي،
حتى أنني كنت مستلقياً هناك تحت الشمس الحارقة
وأدركت أنني كنت قريباً جداً من
الروس ومنك.  حتى أنك بدأت في النظر إلى
بندقيتك بطريقة مختلفة،
لكن كان لدى مشغلي الطائرة بدون طيار خطط أخرى، حيث
قاموا بإرفاق دواء مائي ومذكرة
إلى الطائرة بدون طيار وأرسلوها
مرة أخرى، ووجدته مرة أخرى وأسقطت الحزمة
لكنه لم يكن يعرف ما إذا كانت ودية أم لا  أو
قنبلة روسية
طوال الوقت الذي كنت أزحف فيه، كانت الطائرة بدون طيار
تحوم دائمًا فوقنا ولم ندرك
ما إذا كانت صديقًا أم عدوًا، لقد كانت يانصيب،
هذه هي اللحظة التي يدرك فيها أن الطائرة بدون طيار
قد تنقذه
من الماء والدواء استمر في
التخفيف.  الألم الذي كان مرئيًا حتى
من أعلى ثم زحف عائداً إلى
بر الأمان.
المسعفون القتاليون الذين قدموا لي الإسعافات الأولية
عندما عثروا علي كانوا مندهشين للغاية، لقد
نجوت لمدة يومين برئة مثقوبة
وقالوا إنه يتعافى ويتحدث الآن عن
حياة جديدة.  مع قيمة وهدف أكبر،
لا يريدون ترك أي شخص خلفنا،
قال مشغل الطائرة بدون طيار:
كل حياة مهمة بالنسبة لنا
لا أستطيع العيش مع نفسي إذا تركنا
شخصًا ما خلفنا في الميدان
[تصفيق]
ربما على بعد عدة أميال فقط،
كان الخلاص أقبح  هنا
هجوم أوكراني من قبل الحرس الوطني الخامس عشر على
موقع روسي،
كان شرسًا وأجبر
عشرات القوات الروسية في النهاية على سحب
المدفعية مما أدى إلى إصابة
القائد الروسي بجروح بالغة وتركه الروس
خلفهم على افتراض أنه مات،
لكن هذا الفيديو الذي قدمه الأوكرانيون
تظهر القوات أنها عثرت عليه على قيد الحياة
وأنه تلقى علاجًا طبيًا (
لم نذكر اسمه حفاظًا على سلامته)، لكنه
حصل لاحقًا على ميدالية بعد وفاته
وفقًا لتقارير وسائل الإعلام الروسية التي
تركها رفاقه وأعلن وفاته، ويقول
الأوكرانيون الذين عثروا عليه إنه
ربما يكون قد عثر عليه  تمنينا ألا ينجو،
فقلنا لا تحاول أي شيء وإلا ستموت، كما يقول
وطلب منا أن نطلق النار عليه
وعرضنا عليه فرصة ليفعل ذلك بنفسه
لكنه قال إنه لا يستطيع أن يفعل ذلك
فهو عدو وأنا  لم تكن لدي رغبة حقيقية في
إنقاذه ولكن الأوامر هي أوامر وهم
لديهم رجالنا ويمكننا مبادلة
السجناء
كإنسان. يقول آخر لقد صدمت
لأنهم تركوه وراءهم ولكن
كجندي أعرف عدوي وأعلم أن هذا
ليس بالأمر غير المألوف.  مارس لهم
الأقدار المعاكسة على جوانب مختلفة في
هذه المساحات الواسعة القبيحة من العنف
نيك بايتون والش CNN zapparesia أوكرانيا